- I think my mouth is crying.
(laughter)
(musical chimes)
(fast-paced tempo)
- I'm really looking forward
to this grilled cheese.
I'm just looking forward to see
what's inside this mysterious,
expensive sandwich.
- I'm a little suspicious
of the combination of something fancy
with something that's
pretty cheap and standard.
- I'm really interested to see
what a fancy grilled cheese is like
because I believe the best grilled cheese
is just Kraft singles and bread.
- I think grilled cheese should need
to be sliced triangular.
That's like an important
thing for me, and,
you know, really, when it
comes out on the plate,
if it's not sliced the way I want,
I'm gonna be a little upset.
- Just grab an iron, American cheese...
- No (chuckles).
- Two pieces of white bread...
- Aaaa (gasps).
- And just make that sandwich.
- Then you go to, like, iron your clothes
and you're gonna smell like bread.
- That might be good, though.
- Bread and butter.
That might be kinda hot,
like, you walk into a club,
smell like a grilled cheese (laughs).
- Oh my god.
(rhythmic, upbeat tempo)
- Hi, I'm Joe Calderone at
Serendipity 3 in New York City
and we're here today to
make the Quintessential
Grilled Cheese Sandwich, which
has the Guinness World Record
as the most expensive
sandwich in the world.
- [Clark] What makes it the Quintessential
Grilled Cheese Sandwich?
- Well, first we start with
this beautiful French Pullman
bread that is baked with
Dom Perignon champagne.
- No, shut up.
- Oh my gosh.
- As you can see, it's flecked
with 23-karat edible gold.
(gasps)
What we're gonna do is take
a little white truffle butter
and brush the bread, so when
we put it in our panini press,
it gets a nice, crisp, great flavor.
Then, we're gonna use the
crème de la crème of cheeses,
which is called Caciocavallo
Podolico cheese.
This is from Podolico
cattle in Southern Italy,
of which there are only 25,000 of them.
They graze on aromatic grasses.
- Wow.
- Such as wild strawberry and licorice
and they only lactate in May and June.
- Is that cheese similar
to another kind of cheese?
- It's like a cross between
a manchego and a parmesan,
but it melts really well for
a grilled cheese sandwich.
This is San Marzano, an
African lobster tail bisque.
- Ah, yes. How much does
one of these things cost?
- The Quintessential Grilled Cheese here
at Serendipity is 214 dollars.
- Oh no.
- Okay.
(cash register chime)
- Ade, you've never had lobster bisque
and you also put ketchup
on your grilled cheese,
so please, I'm asking
you, take the first bite.
(gasping)
- Oh my god he went right for the dip.
(squealing)
(classical music)
- Amazing.
- Okay, you're not dippin?
- I'm gonna try my first...
- Okay.
- Non dip.
- [Clark] Oh my god.
(classical music)
Mmm.
- What do you feel?
- I feel rich.
All the flavors have some sort of savory,
like salty quality, but they all
have their own distinct characteristics.
- The lobster bisque
it makes it obviously,
now all the sudden you're
like eatin seafood,
it's very different, but
it really, the flavors
compliment each other.
- Yeah, you have gold on your lips.
(laughter)
That is the most extra
thing I have ever seen.
- I'm just gonna save it for later.
- Okay, I'm just gonna try a gold flake.
- It tastes...
- Doesn't taste like anything.
- Tastes like gold.
- I'm sorry for whoever goes out with me.
I can probably only
afford like one of these.
You might have to get some
crushed ice and water.
- I don't tend to spend 200
plus dollars on my meals,
but I like to imagine a time when
I'm just so freakin wealthy.
- Grilled cheese is a comfort
food, but if I got let go
from a job or I just needed
an ultimate pick-me-up,
this is like, hey, you're
awesome, you're doin fine,
you're worth it, so have
this great grilled cheese.
Are you saying you're having
a bit of a cheese awakening?
- That was very cheesy, yes.
(laughter)
- Oh yeah, you guys.
- It's all Gouda.
- These puns.
(classical music)